for because of our resolve so that let
me answer some questions
that lay uh
out the steps the vice president i are
taking prepare for the rising number of
cases experts tell us
we can expect in the weeks ahead
first how concerned should you be about
omicron
which is now the dominant variant in
this country and it happens so quickly
the answer is straightforward
if you're not fully vaccinated
you have good reason to be concerned
you're at a high risk of getting sick
and if you get sick you're likely to
spread it to others including friends
and family
and the unvaccinated have a
significantly higher risk of ending up
in the hospital
or even dying almost everyone who has
died from coca-19 in the past many
months
has been
unvaccinated
but if you're wrong
among the majority of americans who are
fully vaccinated and especially if
you've gotten the booster shot that
third shot
you're much you have much much less
reason to worry
you have a high degree of protection
against severe illness
because omicron spreads so easily
we'll see some fully vaccinated people
get cold
potentially in large numbers
there will be positive cases in every
office
even here in the white house among the
unveil among the vaccinated among the
vaccinated
from omicron
but these cases are highly unlikely to
lead to serious illness
vaccinated people who get common
may get ill
but they're protected
from severe illness and death
that's why you should still remain
vigilant
according to our doctors
even if you're fully vaccinated you
should wear a mask
when indoors and in public settings
wearing a mask provides extra protection
for you and those around you and i know
some americans are wondering
if you can safely celebrate the holidays
with your family and friends
the answer is yes you can
if you and those who celebrate with are
vaccinated particularly if you've gotten
your booster shot
if you are vaccinated and follow the
precautions that we all know well
you should feel comfortable celebrating
christmas and the holidays as you
planned it
you know you've done the right thing
you can enjoy the holiday season
and thanks to the progress on
vaccinations this fall
we've gone from nearly 90 million adults
in july who have not even started their
vaccination process
to fewer than 40 million today
still too many
but down from 90 to 40.
all these people who have not been
vaccinated
you have an obligation to yourselves
to your family and quite frankly i
normally criticize for this to your
country
get vaccinated now it's free
it's convenient
i promise you it saves lives
and i honestly gotta believe it's your
patriotic duty
another question
folks are asking is what can you do to
make yourself and your family feel safer
and be safer
the answer is simple
get your booster shot
wear a mask
our doctors have made it clear booster
shots provide the strongest of
protections unfortunately
we still have tens of millions of people
who are eligible for the booster shot
people have not yet gotten i've gotten
the first two shots
but they've not gotten the booster
folks
the booster shots are free
and widely available
over 60 million americans
including 62 percent of eligible seniors
our most vulnerable group have gotten
their booster shots
i got my booster shot
as soon as they were available
and just the other day former president
trump announced he had gotten his
booster shot
maybe one of the few things he and i
agree on
people with booster shots are highly
protected
join them join us
it's been six months or more since my
second shot
if it's been six months or more for your
second shot when i got my booster you
can get yours today you've been six
months or more since your second shot
another question that folks are asking
is are we going back to march 2020 not
just last march 2021
but march 2020 when the pandemic first
hit
and that's what i keep getting asked the
answer is absolutely no
no
there are three big differences between
then and now
one
number one first one
more than 200 million americans have
been fully vaccinated in march
no one was fully vaccinated
what that means is today
as cases a case of covet 19 for fully
vaccinated and boosted person will most
likely mean no symptoms or mild ones
similar to the common respiratory
viruses
over 200 million americans should have a
peace of mind that they did not have in
march of 2020
they're protected
from hospitalization and are protected
from death
second point
we're prepared today for what's coming
in march of 2020 we were not ready
today we spock tile enough we stockpiled
enough gowns mass and ventilators to
deal with the surge of hospitalizations
among the unvaccinated
today we're ready
and as i'll explain in a few minutes
we're going to be reinforcing our
hospitals helping them
number three
we know a lot more today than we did
back in march of 2020.
for example
last year we thought the only way to
keep your children safe was to close
your close our schools
today we know more and we have more
resources to keep those schools open
we you can get five to 11 year olds
vaccinated
tool we didn't have until last month
today
we don't have to shut down schools
because of the case of coven 19.
now if a student tests positive other
students can take the test and stay in
the classroom if they're not infected
rather than closing the whole school or
having a quarantine
we can keep our k-12 schools open
that's exactly what we should be doing
so folks let me summarize
we should all be concerned about omicron
but not panicked
if you're fully vaccinated and
especially if you got your booster shot
you are highly protected
if you're unvaccinated
you're at a higher risk of being
severely ill from covert 19 getting
hospitalized and even dying
so the best thing to do is get fully
vaccinated and get your booster shot
and no this is not march of 2020.
200 million people are fully vaccinated
we're prepared we know more
we just have to stay focused
so that's where we stand
now let me tell you about the additional
steps i'm ordering today to take on what
is coming i know you've heard a lot of
this in the news already this morning
weeks ago
i laid out a covet 19 action plan for
this winter
that prepared us for this moment
today
we're making the plan even stronger
first
we're setting up our vaccination and
booster efforts we're stepping it up
significantly
in the past two weeks we've seen the
highest vaccination rates since last
spring
and we aren't as vaccinated as a country
as we should be though that's why we
have added 10 000 new vaccination sites
on top of the 80 000 sites that are
already we had we already had in place
and even more will open in january
know there's some parts of this country
where people are very eager to get their
booster
where it's harder to get an appointment
excuse me
so starting this week
i'll be deploying hundreds more
vaccinators
and more sites to help get the booster
shots in people's arms
i've ordered fema the federal emergency
management agency to stand up new pop-up
vaccination clinics all across the
country
where you can get that booster shot
we've opened
excuse me we opened fema vaccination
sites in washington state and new mexico
recently as cases have increased
and today i'm directing fema to stand up
new sites in areas where there is a high
demand
these steps are going to help us add
more
more and more booster appointments and
over the just over the next few weeks
i also want to say a word to parents
if your children are not vaccinated
please get them vaccinated
if you're a parent understandably who
waited
to see how the first shots went with
other kids before getting your own kid
vaccinated you can stop waiting
six million children in our country ages
five to eleven are vaccinated
get your children protected today now
for those parents out there who have a
child that's too young to be vaccinated
that is under the age of five
i know this can still be a scary time
but one thing
one thing you can and must do
while we await vaccines for children
under five
get yourself fully vaccinated and
boosted
as well as those around you
your children your caregivers your
siblings
it's critical to mask up in public
indoor places
we know that our youngest children
have only rarely been impacted by
serious covert case uh coca-19 cases
but they can be further predicted if
they're surrounded by vaccinated people
and again to folks who are not
vaccinated
you might think you're putting only
yourself at risk
but it's your choice
your choice is not just a choice about
you it affects other people
you're putting other people at risk your
loved ones your friends neighbors
strangers you run into
and your choice can be the difference
between life or death
the longer the virus is around
the more likely variants form
it may be deadlier than the ones that
have come before
let me say again and again and again and
again
please get vaccinated
it's the only responsible thing to do
those were not vaccinated or causing
hospitals to over run become overrun
again
i just spoke to the governor of new york
every covet 19 hospital means someone
with a heart attack cancer other serious
illness may not get that bed and that
life-saving care they need in the
hospital
look let me give it to you straight
again
omicron is serious potentially deadly
business for unvaccinated people let me
be clear
thanks to the prior administration and
our scientific community america is one
of the first countries to get the
vaccine
thanks to my administration and the hard
work of americans
we let a rollout made america among the
world leaders in getting shots and arms
but uptakes slowed this summer
as vaccine resistance among some
hardened
look
the unvaccinated are responsible for
their own choices
but those choices have been fueled by
dangerous misinformation on cable tv and
social media
you know these companies and
personalities are making money
by peddling lies and allowing
misinformation that can kill their own
customers and their own supporters
it's wrong
it's immoral
i call on the purveyors of these lies
and misinformation to stop it
stop it now
one of the other things that we know
that has to be done
is more testing
because omicron spreads easily
especially among the unvaccinated it's
critically important that we know who's
infected
that means we need more testing
on that score we're now where we should
be
yes we have over 20 000 free testing
sites
yes we've used the defense production
act and spent three billion dollars
to greatly expand the number of at-home
tests available for purchase online and
at your local pharmacy and yes
we made sure insurance covers the pcr
tests you get in the hospital or at your
doctor's office
but starting next month
private insurance will all cover also
cover at home testing
so you can order a test online and get
reimbursed
we're providing access to free at-home
tests for those who may have insurance
as well may not have insurance i should
say as well
but it's not enough
we have to do more
we have to do better
and we will
starting this week
the federal government will set up
emergency testing sites
in areas that need additional testing
capacity
before christmas
the first several of these federal
testing sites will be up and running in
new york city
with many more to come
this free testing is going to help
reduce the waiting lines
the time you have to stand there
and sometimes it's hour or more
we're going to continue to add federal
testing sites where needed so that if
you want an immediate test to be a place
where you can go get it
we also need to do better with at-home
testing so i'm announcing today
the federal government will purchase one
half billion that's not million billion
with a b
additional at home rapid tests with
delivery starting in january
we'll be getting these tests to
americans for free
we'll have websites where you can get
them delivered to your home
we've arranged for it to be easier for
you to find a free copa testing site
near you on google
just enter cova test near me the google
search bar
and you can find a number of different
locations nearby where you can get
tested
we're going to continue to use the
defense production act
as we did earlier this month to make
sure we're producing as many tests and
as quickly as possible
the bottom line
is it's a lot better than it was
but we're taking even more steps to make
it easier to get tested and get tested
for free
next
we're preparing hospitals for what's
coming
those 40 unvaccinated adults
have a good chance of getting covert 19
and some of you will get very sick
lol main hospital is going to get
extremely stressed
extremely stressed again
both in terms of equipment
as well as personnel to care for those
who get sick
that's why my administration
has stockpiled and pre-positioned
millions of gowns
gloves
masks and ventilators it's called a ppp
we're ready to send them immediately to
any state that needs more
in addition i've directed the pentagon
to mobilize an additional 1 000 troops
to be deployed to help staff local
hospitals and expand capacity
that's one thousand military doctors
nurses and medics
we've already started moving military
and excuse me medical teams
they've already landed in wisconsin
indiana this week
this is on top of 300 federal medical
medical personnel that are now on the
ground
having deployed since we learned about
overcrowd
look
while we know staffing is the biggest
need for hospitals
some may need more beds as well
we're prepared i've directed fema to
activate the national response center
and begin deploying teams now to provide
additional hospital beds
we'll begin to construct emergency
capacities near hospitals in parking
garages and nearby buildings to be ready
if needed
and the full the federal government is
paying for all of this period all of it
further
fema will deploy hundreds of ambulances
and ems crews so that if
one hospital fills up we can transport
patients to beds elsewhere
this week
we'll send dozens of ambulances to new
york and maine because of because the
covert is spreading very rapidly
to help transport patients
our doctors nurses hospital staffs have
gone above and beyond during this
pandemic
the strain of stress is real i really
mean it it's real
and we'll have their backs though we
have to let them know we have their
backs
finally
we're making sure the covet 19 no longer
closes businesses or schools
last week
the federal court reinstated my
administration's vaccination or test
the vaccination of test rule for
businesses with more than 100 employees
law requires employers with 100 more
employees to protect their workers who
are on site and indoors with the
requirement that they be vaccinated or
tested each week or go home
these rules are going to keep workers
safe and keep workers safe will help
keep businesses open
people are vaccinated or tested
they're much less likely to get sick and
less likely to spread into others
customers are more likely to come in and
shop
because they know it's a safe
environment
i know vaccination requirements are
unpopular
for many
not even popular for those who are
anxious to get them
my administration has put them in place
not to control your life but to save
your life
in the lives of others
where 400 000 americans died from covert
this calendar year
and almost all were unvaccinated almost
all were preventable
rule is legal and effective
it's going to save thousands of american
lives
must also keep our k-12 schools open
look the science is clear
and overwhelming
we know how to keep our kids safe from
covet 19 in school
k through 12 schools should be open
and that safety is increased if schools
require all adults who work in the
schools to get vaccinated
and take the safety measure that the cdc
is recommended including masking
i got congress to pass
billions of dollars in school
improvements
ventilation and social distances
schools should be safer than ever
from covet 19.
and just friday the cdc issued a test to
stay guidelines
so schools can stay open and kids can
stay in class even if a classmate tests
positive cover 19 is scary but the
science is clear
children are safe and
as safe in schools they're already
placed assuming the appropriate
precautions have been taken and they've
already been funded
let me close with this i know you're
tired
i really mean this and i know you're
frustrated
we all want this to be over
but we're still in it
this is a critical moment
but also have more tools we've ever had
before
we're ready
we'll get through this
as we head into the holidays
want us to all keep the faith
i want to sincerely thank you for your
perseverance your courage your countless
acts of kindness love and sacrifice
during these last two years
throughout our history
we've been tested as a people and as a
nation
through war and turmoil
we'd ask whether we'd be safe
whether it be okay
whether we get back to who we are
we've always endured because remember
there's no challenge too big for america
i mean this bottom heart no challenge
we've come through better and stronger
because we stay together
as the united states of america
that's what we have to keep doing today
we can do this together
i guarantee you
may god bless you all
and may god protect our troops
and
happy holidays
you said we have to do better but public
health officials have been saying for
months you need to surge rapid tests for
just this moment is it a failure that
you don't have an adequate amount of
tests for everyone to be able to get one
if they need one right now no it's not
because covet
is
spreading so rapidly you notice
it just it just happened almost
overnight just the last month
i don't think anybody anticipated that
this was going to be as rapidly
spreading as it did
and so the question is we had a lot of
people who have access
to tests who could order them could
could have their insurance pay for them
etc but it also and all of a sudden it
was like everybody rushed to the counter
it was a big big rush
and i knew that was coming so what i
tried to do is meet with the companies
and use the defense production act to
get a half a billion more tests and
figure out how to get them to their
homes
get them on the shelves
in the store i mean so that that's what
it's all about yes mr president what's
your message to americans who are trying
to get tested now and who are not able
to get tested and who are wondering what
took so long to ramp up testing come on
what took so long
i'm hearing that from people who are
trying to get tested now before the
holidays
what took so long didn't take long at
all
what happened was
the omicron virus spread even more
rapidly than anybody thought if i told
you
four weeks ago that this would spread by
on a day-to-day basis
it would spread by 50 100 200 500
i think you would have looked to me and
said biden what are you drinking
but that's what it did
now we don't know what's going to happen
from here
it looks there's some evidence that in
south africa where a lot of this started
that it's dropping off quickly too we
don't know
but i do know that we're not going to be
in a position like i said when we
remember we were having a problem with
masks and gowns and the like
i said i promise you remember the
criticism i got questions from some of
you why are you still paying for all
these masking gowns why are you
stockpiling this
because we don't know
turns out we're going to need
in the back and then
work sir and will you reverse the travel
ban now that omicron's so prevalent here
in the u.s i'm considering reversion i'm
going to talk with my team in the next
couple of days
um
look remember why i said we put the
travel ban on
is to see how much time we had before it
hit here so we could begin to decide
what we needed by looking at what's
happening in other countries
and but we're past that now
and so uh it's something that is being
raised with me by the docs and i'll have
an answer for that soon
about the importance of keeping your
word of trust do you believe senator
manchin kept his word to you and how do
you rebuild trust with progressives in
your party to advance your legislation
now
you know i told you before you've heard
me say this before
some people
think maybe i'm not irish-based i don't
hold a grudge
look i want to get things done i still
think there's a possibility of getting
buildback better done what i don't want
to do is get into and joe went on tv
today and
uh not was tv or not i'm told he was
speaking to
a liberal caucus in the house and said
joe biden did this thing
and so look i'm not i'm not looking for
let me say something
you saw what happened yesterday
all the talk about how my build back
better plan was going to increase
inflation causes debts and all the like
what happened goldman sachs never said
if we don't pass bill back better we're
in trouble
because it's going to grow the economy
without it we're not going to grow
and what happened
stock prices went way down
it took a real dip
if you take a look
i wasn't everybody thinks because i
quoted
17 nobel laureates saying this is going
to help inflation think about it in
terms of
you're a hard-working person
and you're making 60 grand if you're
alone or your mom just on your own or if
you're making 80 grand mom and dad 90
grand like a lot of people do
and you're worried about inflation you
should be worried about because it's a
devastating thing for people who are
working class and middle class folks it
really hurts
where is most of the cost now the cost
is finding in gasoline even though i put
i was able to bring it down 12 cents a
gallon will come down more i believe
we talked about what the cost of food
prices going up et cetera
but look what's in
look who's going to go back better
child care you can reduce it by up to 70
percent that'll be the difference
between 20 million women who aren't back
in the workforce being able to go back
if you pass it we're talking about we're
talking about healthcare
insulin and essentially we got we got
200 000 kids with type 1 diabetes
you know it's costing it cost somewhere
between 10 cents and 10 to come up with
the formula okay a while ago
right
you know what it's costing on average
560 dollars 640 a month
up to a thousand dollars a month
what do you do
if you're a mom and a dad working with
minimum wage busting your neck you look
at your kid
and you know if you don't get that
vaccine for them i'm that excuse me if
you don't get that drug for them
if you don't get that that be able to
take that
what happens
they're likely to go in a coma maybe die
i don't want you to put the kid's life
at stake
you strip away all the dignity
of a parent
looking at their child i'm not joking
about this imagine being a parent
looking at a child
and you can't afford
you have no house to borrow against
you have no savings
it's wrong
but all the things in that bill
are going to reduce prices
and costs for middle class and working
class people
it's going to reduce
their
cost what what's inflation having to pay
more than the money you have because
things have gone up
well bring down all those costs across
the board from child care to a child
care tax credit
but i'm not supposed to be having this
press conference
would you support family mr president
did senator manchin break his commitment
to you when you announced the framework
the white house says that all 50
senators were believed to get behind it
out of the democratic senators so did
senator manchin break his commitment to
you
senator manchin i am going to get
something done thank
sir do you still have a card
so
acknowledging how tired
worried and frustrated i know you are
i know how you're feeling for many of
you this will be the first or even the
second christmas
where you look across the table be an
empty kitchen chair there tens of
millions have gotten sick
we've all experienced upheaval in our
lives
but while covet has been
a tough adversary we've shown that we're
tougher
tougher because we have the power of
science and vaccines that prevent
illness and save lives
and tougher because of our resolve so
that let me answer some questions
that lay uh
out the steps the vice president i are
taking prepare for the rising number of
cases experts tell us
we can expect in the weeks ahead
first
how concerned should you be about
omicron
which is now the dominant variant in
this country and it happened so quickly
the answer is straightforward
if you're not fully vaccinated
you have good reason to be concerned
you're at a high risk of getting sick
and if you get sick you're likely to
spread it to others including friends
and family
and the unvaccinated have a
significantly higher risk of ending up
in a hospital
or even dying
almost everyone who has died from covert
19 in the past many months
has been unvaccinated
unvaccinated
but if you're wrong
among the majority of americans who are
fully vaccinated and especially if
you've gotten the booster shot that
third shot
you're much you have much much less
reason to worry
you have a high degree of protection
against severe illness
because omicron spreads so easily
we'll see some fully vaccinated people
get cold
potentially in large numbers
there'll be positive cases in every
office
even here in the white house among the
unba among the vaccinated among the
vaccinated
from from omaha
but these cases are highly unlikely to
lead to serious illness
vaccinated people who get common may get
ill but they're protected from severe
illness and death
that's why you should still remain
vigilant according to our doctors
even if you're fully vaccinated you
should wear a mask
when indoors in public settings
wearing a mask provides extra protection
for you and those around you and i know
some americans are wondering
if you can safely celebrate the holidays
with your family and friends
the answer is yes you can
if you and those you celebrate with are
vaccinated
particularly if you've gotten your
booster shot
if you are vaccinated and follow the
precautions that we all know well
you should feel comfortable celebrating
christmas and the holidays as you
planned it
you know you've done the right thing
because you enjoy the holiday season
and thanks to the progress on
vaccinations this fall
we've gone from nearly 90 million adults
in july who have not even started their
vaccination process
to fewer than 40 million today
still too many
but down from 90 to 40.
all these people who have not been
vaccinated
you have an obligation to yourselves
to your family and quite frankly i
normally criticize for this to your
country
get vaccinated now it's free
it's convenient
i promise you it saves lives
and i honestly god believe it's your
patriotic duty
another question
folks are asking is what can you do to
make yourself and your family feel safer
and be safer
the answer is simple get your booster
shot
wear a mask
our doctors have made it clear booster
shots provide the strongest of
protection unfortunately
we still have tens of millions of people
who are eligible for the booster shot
people who have not yet gotten gotten
the first two shots
but they've not gotten the booster
folks
the booster shots are free
and widely available
over 60 million americans
including 62 percent of eligible seniors
our most vulnerable group have gotten
their booster shots
i got my booster shot
as soon as they were available
and just the other day former president
trump announced he had gotten his
booster shot
maybe one of the few things he and i
agree on
people with booster shots are highly
protected
join them join us
it's been six months or more since my
second shot
if it's been six months or more for your
second shot when i got my booster you
can get yours today you've been six
months or more since your second shot
another question that folks are asking
is are we going back to march 2020 not
just last march 2021
but march 2020 when the pandemic first
hit
and that's what i keep getting asked the
answer is absolutely no
no
there are three big differences between
then and
now one
number one first one
more than 200 million americans have
been fully vaccinated
in march
no one was fully
vaccinated what that means is today
as cases a case of covet 19 for fully
vaccinated and boosted person will most
likely mean no symptoms or mild ones
similar to the common respiratory
viruses
over 200 million americans should have a
peace of mind that they did not have in
march of 2020
they're protected
from hospitalization and are protected
from death
second point we're prepared today for
what's coming
in march of 2020 we were not ready
today we spot tile and up we stockpiled
enough gowns mass and ventilators to
deal with the surge of hospitalizations
unvaccinated
today we're ready
and as i'll explain in a few minutes
we're going to be reinforcing our
hospitals helping them
number three
we know a lot more today than we did
back in march of 2020.
for example
last year we thought the only way to
keep your children safe was to close
close our schools
today we know more and we have more
resources to keep those schools open
we you can get five to 11 year olds
vaccinated
two we didn't have until last month
today
we don't have to shut down schools
because of the case of covert 19.
now if a student test positive other
students can take the test and stay in
the classroom if they're not infected
rather than closing the whole school or
having a quarantine
we can keep our k-12 schools open
that's exactly what we should be doing
so folks let me summarize we should all
be concerned about omicron
but not panicked
if you're fully vaccinated and
especially if you got your booster shot
you are highly protected
if you're unvaccinated
you're at a higher risk of being
severely ill from covert 19 getting
hospitalized and even dying
so the best thing to do is get fully
vaccinated and get your booster shot
and no this is not march of 2020.
200 million people are fully vaccinated
we're prepared we know more we just have
to stay focused
so that's where we stand
now let me tell you about the additional
steps i'm ordering today to take on what
is coming i know you've heard a lot of
this in the news already this morning
three weeks ago
i laid out a covet 19 action plan for
this winter
that prepared us for this moment
today
we're making the plan even stronger
first
we're setting up our vaccination and
booster efforts we're stepping it up
significantly
in the past two weeks we've seen the
highest vaccination rates since last
spring
and we aren't as vaccinated as a country
as we should be though
that's why we have added 10 000 new
vaccination sites
on top of the 80 000 sites that are
already we had we already had in place
and even more will open in january
i know there's some parts of this
country where people are very eager to
get their booster
where it's harder to get an appointment
excuse me
so starting this week
i'll be deploying hundreds more
vaccinators
and more sites to help get the booster
shots in people's arms
i've ordered fema the federal emergency
management agency to stand up new pop-up
vaccination clinics all across the
country
where you can get that booster shot
we've opened
excuse me we opened fema vaccination
sites in washington state and new mexico
recently as cases have increased
and today i'm directing fema to stand up
new sites in areas where there is a high
demand
these steps are going to help us add
more
more and more booster appointments and
over than just over the next few weeks
i also want to say a word to parents
if your children are not vaccinated
please get them vaccinated
if you're a parent understandably who
waited what to see how the first shots
went with other kids before getting your
own kid vaccinated you can stop waiting
six million children in our country ages
five to eleven are vaccinated
get your children protected today now
for those parents out there who have a
child that's too young to be vaccinated
that is under the age of five
i know this can still be a scary time
but one thing one thing you can and must
do
while we await vaccines for children
under five
get yourself fully vaccinated and
boosted
as well as those around you
your children your caregivers your
siblings
it's critical to mask up in public
indoor places
we know that our youngest children
have only rarely been impacted by
serious cobot case uh cover 19 cases but
they can be further predicted if they're
surrounded by vaccinated people
and again to folks who are not
vaccinated you might think you're
putting only yourself at risk
but it's your choice your choice is not
just a choice about you it affects other
people
you're putting other people at risk
your loved ones your friends neighbors
strangers you run into
and your choice can be the difference
between life or death
the longer the virus is around
the more likely variants form
it may be deadlier than the ones that
have come before
let me say again and again and again and
again
please get vaccinated
it's the only responsible thing to do
those who are not vaccinated or causing
hospitals to over
run become overrun again
i just spoke to the governor of new york
every covet 19 hospital means someone
with a heart attack cancer other serious
illness may not get that bed and that
life-saving care they need in the
hospital
look let me give it to you straight
again
omicron is serious potentially deadly
business for unvaccinated people
let me be clear
thanks to the prior administration and
our scientific community america is one
of the first countries to get the
vaccine
thanks to my administration and the hard
work of americans
we led a rollout made america among the
world leaders in getting shots and arms
but uptakes slowed this summer as
vaccine resistance among some hardened
look
the unvaccinated are responsible for
their own choices
but those choices have been fueled by
dangerous misinformation on cable tv and
social media
you know these companies and
personalities are making money
by peddling lies and allowing
misinformation that can kill their own
customers and their own supporters
it's wrong it's immoral
i call on the purveyors of these lies
and misinformation to stop it
stop it now
one of the other things that we know
that has to be done is more testing
because omicron spreads easily
especially among the unvaccinated it's
critically important that we know who's
infected
that means we need more testing
on that score we're now where we should
be
yes we have over 20 000 free testing
sites
yes we've used the defense production
act and spent three billion dollars
to greatly expand the number of at-home
tests available for purchase online and
at your local pharmacy yes
we made sure insurance covers the pcr
tests you get in the hospital or at your
doctor's office
but starting next month
private insurance will all cover also
cover at-home testing
so you can order a test online and get
reimbursed
we're providing access to free at home
tests for those who may have insurance
as well may not have insurance i should
say as well but it's not enough
we have to do more
we have to do better
and we will
starting this week
the federal government will set up
emergency testing sites
in areas that need additional testing
capacity
before christmas
the first several of these federal
testing sites will be up and running in
new york city
with many more to come
this free testing is going to help
reduce the waiting lines the time you
have to stand there
and sometimes it's an hour or more
we're going to continue to add federal
testing sites where needed
so if you want an immediate test
to be a place where you can go get it we
also need to do better with at-home
testing so i'm announcing today
the federal government will purchase
one-half billion
that's not million billion with a b
additional at-home rapid test with
delivery starting in january
we'll be getting these tests to
americans for free
we'll have websites where you can get
them delivered to your home
we've arranged for it to be easier for
you to find a free copa testing site
near you on google
just enter cova test near me
the google search bar
and you can find a number of different
locations nearby where you can get
tested we're going to continue to use
the defense production act
as we did earlier this month to make
sure we're producing as many tests and
as quickly as possible
the bottom line
is it's a lot better than it was but
we're taking even more steps to make it
easier to get tested and get tested for
free
next
we're preparing hospitals for what's
coming
those 40 unvaccinated adults
have a good chance of getting covert 19
and some of you will get very sick
little main hospitals are going to get
extremely stressed
extremely stressed again
both in terms of equipment
as well as personnel to care for those
who get sick
that's why my administration
has stockpiled and pre-positioned
millions of gowns
gloves
masks and ventilators called a ppp
we're ready to send them immediately to
any state that needs more
in addition i've directed the pentagon
to mobilize an additional 1 000 troops
to be deployed to help staff local
hospitals and expand capacity
that's 1 000 military doctors nurses and
medics
who've already started moving military
and excuse me medical teams
they've already landed in wisconsin
indiana this week
this is on top of 300 federal medical
medical personnel that are now on the
ground
having deployed since we learned about
overcrowd
look
while we know staffing is the biggest
need for hospitals
some may need more beds as well
we're prepared
i've directed fema to activate the
national response center and begin
deploying teams now to provide
additional hospital beds
we'll begin to construct emergency
capacities near hospitals in parking
garages and nearby buildings to be ready
if needed
and the full the federal government is
paying for all of this period all of it
further
fema will deploy hundreds of ambulances
and ems crews so that if
one hospital fills up we can transport
patients to beds elsewhere
this week
we'll send dozens of ambulances to new
york and maine because of because the
covet is spreading very rapidly
to help transport patients
our doctors nurses hospital staffs have
gone above and beyond during this
pandemic the strain of stress is real i
really mean it it's real
and we'll have their backs though we
have to let them know we have their
backs
finally
we're making sure the covet 19 no longer
closes businesses or schools
last week
the federal court reinstated my
administration's vaccination or test
the vaccination of test rule for
businesses with more than 100 employees
the war requires employers with a
hundred and more employees to protect
their workers who are on site and
indoors with the requirement that they
be vaccinated or tested each week or go
home
these rules are going to keep workers
safe and keep workers safe will help
keep businesses open
people are vaccinated or tested
they're much less likely to get sick and
less likely to spread into others
customers are more likely to come in and
shop
because they know it's a safe
environment
i know vaccination requirements are
unpopular
for many
they're not even popular for those who
are anxious to get them
my administration has put them in place
not to control your life but to save
your life
in the lives of others
where four hundred thousand americans
died from covet this calendar year
and almost all were unvaccinated almost
all were preventable
rule is legal and effective
it's going to save thousands of american
lives
must also keep our k-12 schools open
look the science is
clear and overwhelming
we know how to keep our kids safe from
covet 19 in school
k through 12 schools should be open
and that safety is increased if schools
require all adults
who work in the schools to get
vaccinated
and take the safety measure that the cdc
is recommending including masking
i got congress to pass
billions of dollars in school
improvements
ventilation and social distances
schools should be safer than ever
from covet 19.
and just friday the cdc issued a test to
stay guidelines
so schools can stay open and kids can
stay in class even if a classmate tests
positive
cover 19 is scary but the science is
clear
children are safe and
as safe in schools they already placed
assuming the appropriate precautions
have been taken and they've already been
funded
let me close with this
i know you're tired
i really mean this and i know you're
frustrated
we all want this to be over
but we're still in it
and this is a critical moment
but also more tools we've ever had
before
we're ready
we'll get through this
as we head into the holidays
want us to all keep the faith
i want to sincerely thank you for your
perseverance your courage countless acts
of kindness love and sacrifice
during these last two years
throughout our history
we've been tested as a people and as a
nation
through war and turmoil
we'd ask whether we'd be safe
whether it be okay
whether we get back to who we are
we've always endured because remember
there is no challenge too big for
america i mean this from the bottom of
heart no challenge
we've come through better and stronger
because we stay together
as the united states of america
that's what we have to keep doing today
we can do this together
i guarantee you
may god bless you all and may god
protect our troops
and
happy holidays god love you all thank
you
mr president mr president mr president
i'm testing i'm testing sir you said we
have to do better but public health
officials have been saying for months
you need to surge rapid tests for just
this moment is it a failure that you
don't have an adequate amount of tests
for everyone to be able to get one if
they need one right now no it's not
because covet
is
spreading so rapidly you notice
it just it just happened almost
overnight just in the last month
but the alarm bell went off i don't
think anybody
anticipated that this was going to be as
rapidly spreading as it did
and so the question is we had a lot of
people who have access
to tests who could order them could
could have their insurance pay for them
etc but it all started all of a sudden
it was like everybody rushed to the
counter it was a big big rush
and i knew that was coming so what i
tried to do is meet with the companies
and use the defense production act to
get a half a billion more tests and
figure out how to get them to their
homes
get them on the shelves
in the store i mean so that that's what
it's all about yes mr president what's
your message to americans who are trying
to get tested now and who are not able
to get tested and who are wondering what
took so long to ramp up testing come on
what took so long
i'm hearing that from people who are
trying to get tested now before the
holidays well
what took so long didn't take long at
all
what happened was
the omicron virus spread
even more rapidly than anybody thought
if i told you
four weeks ago that this would spread by
a day-to-day basis
it would spread by 50 100 200 500
i think you would have looked to me and
said biden what are you drinking
but that's what it did
now we don't know what's going to happen
from here
it looks there's some evidence that in
south africa where a lot of this started
that is dropping off quickly too we
don't know
but i do know that we're not going to be
in a position like i said when we
remember we were having problem with
masks and gowns and the like
i said i promise you remember the
criticism i got questions from some of
you why are you still paying for all
these masking gowns why are you
stockpiling this
because we don't know it turns out we're
going to meet
in the back and then
does it work sir and will you reverse
the travel ban now that omicron's so
prevalent here in the u.s i'm
considering reversion i'm going to talk
with my team in the next couple of days
um
look remember why i said we put the
travel ban on
is to see how much time we had before it
hit here so we could begin to decide
what we needed by looking at what's
happening in other countries
and but we're past that now
and so
it's something that is being raised with
me by the docs and i'll have an answer
for that soon
do you believe senator manchin kept his
word to you and how do you rebuild trust
with progressives in your party to
advance your legislation enough
you know i told you before you've heard
me say this before
some people
think maybe i'm not irish people don't
hold a grudge
look i want to get things done i still
think there's a possibility of getting
pulled back better done
what i don't want to do is get into and
joe went on tv today and
uh not on his tv or not i'm told he was
speaking to
a liberal caucus in the house and said
joe biden didn't mislead you i missed it
and so look i'm not i'm not looking for
let me say something
you saw what happened yesterday
all the talk about how my build back
better plan was going to increase
inflation and causes debts and all the
what happened goldman sachs another said
if we don't pass bill back better we're
in trouble
because it's going to grow the economy
without it we're not going to grow
and what happened
stock prices went way down it took a
real dip
if you take a look
i wasn't everybody thinks because i
quoted
17 nobel laureates saying this is going
to help inflation think about it in
terms of you're a hard-working person
and you're making 60 grand if you're
alone or your mom or just on your own or
if you're making 80 grand mom and dad 90
grand like a lot of people do
and you're worried about inflation you
should be worried about because it's a
devastating thing for people who are
working class and middle class folks it
really hurts
where is most of the costs now the cost
is finding in gasoline even though i put
i was able to bring it down 12 cents a
gallon will come down more i believe
we talked about what the cost of food
prices going up et cetera
but look what's in l what does them go
back better
child care you can reduce it by up to 70
percent that'll be the difference
between 20 million women who aren't back
in the workforce being able to go back
if you pass it we're talking about we're
talking about health care insulin and
essentially we got we got 200 000 kids
with type 1
diabetes
you know it's costing it cost somewhere
between 10 cents and 10 to come up with
the formula okay a while ago
right
you know what it's costing on average
560.
six hundred forty dollars a month
up to a thousand dollars a month
what do you do
if you're a mom and a dad
working with minimum wage busting your
neck you look at your kid
and you know if you don't get that
vaccine for that excuse me if you don't
get that drug for him
if you don't get that that that be able
to take that
what happens
you're likely to go in a coma maybe die
i don't want you to put the kid's life
at stake you strip away all the dignity
of a parent
looking at their child i'm not joking
about this imagine being a parent
looking at a child and you can't afford
you have no house to borrow against
you have no savings
it's wrong
but all the things in that bill
are going to reduce prices and costs for
middle-class and working-class people
it's going to reduce
their
cost what what's inflation having to pay
more than the money you have because
things have gone up
will bring down all those costs across
the board from child care to a child
care tax credit
but i'm not supposed to be having this
press conference
president did senator manchin break his
commitment to you when you announced the
framework the white house says that all
50 senators were believed to get behind
it all with the democratic senators so
did senator manchin break his commitment
to you
senator manch and i are going to get
something done thank you
start by acknowledging how tired